firebase a suite of tools for building
apps and managing infrastructure on top
of google cloud platform it was founded
by james tamplin and andrew lee in 2011
after they discovered that developers
were using their chat software to manage
non-chat application data this inspired
them to create a real-time database a
json database that automatically stays
in sync with your front-end application
it was later expanded to support user
authentication and website hosting to
act as a complete backend as a service
in 2014 it was acquired by google where
it was further expanded with serverless
computing via cloud functions push
notifications via cloud messaging and
other google services like analytics and
admob in 2017 google acquired fabric
from twitter and also launched a new
document database called firestore to
support a wider range of applications
most importantly though firebase
provides software development kits for
virtually every platform to manage and
scale this infrastructure with little to
no back-end code to build a full stack
application right now create a free
firebase project then open up some code
for your favorite front-end platform
install the firebase sdk then connect it
to the cloud with your project
credentials once initialized you can
start interacting with your backend
resources first we might want to know if
the user is logged in or not we can
listen to the current user with the on
off state changed function the user will
be null at first but we can log them in
with their google account using the sign
in with pop-up function now that we have
a user logged in we might want to store
something in a database we can make a
reference to a document in firestore
then write json data to it while making
a reference to the current user's user
id but the amazing thing is that we can
listen to updates to that data in real
time by simply referencing the document
using the onsnapshot function anytime
the data changes on the server it'll be
reflected in the ui with zero latency
thanks to optimistic updates out of the
box but that doesn't seem very secure
how do we control who has access to the
database firestore security rules allow
you to define access control logic in a
simple readable format with common
expression language you can do almost
everything from the front end but when
you do need to run server-side code
firebase cloud functions provides a
tightly integrated serverless backend
not only does it allow you to create
http endpoints but functions can also be
triggered in the background based on
events that happen in your project like
rights to the database user
authentication events file uploads and
many others when developing locally
firebase has an emulator suite to run
and test your code in a mock environment
when it's time to deploy run the
firebase deploy command to push your
code to the cloud and allocate
infrastructure to run it at any scale
this has been firebase in 100 seconds if
you're ready to build a serious app with
firebase i can think of no better place
to learn than fireship io the web app i
built with firebase to teach firebase
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one